okay guys I have news for you that may
surprise you we may not have a second
wave of coronavirus but the reason why
is not so good it's because the first
wave may actually never end we are
already now halfway into June and it
doesn't seem like the first wave is
going to end at least at the national
level because of a number of new
exploding exploding hot spots the
out-of-control case growth is happening
overwhelmingly in Trump states states
with Republican governors so first let's
get this out of the way cuz I know
people are going to want me to talk
about California now California is the
exception here California is is a state
with a Democratic governor they have
been on paper locked down for a very
long time but things are not going well
in California I have no interest in
hiding this from you California has been
so-called closed for months but their
cases are going higher and higher
not precipitously but they are going up
it's not clear what's going on my
brother lives in LA says seems a lot of
people are just ignoring the guidelines
that he drove by some restaurants that
were open with people sitting inside
without masks so it seems as though
what's happening in California at least
Southern California is people are just
ignoring the guidelines that are in
place but most of the early contagion
states that were early hotspots have
curves that are looking really really
good an example of that is New York
State dramatically turning their curve
around here in Massachusetts I'm just
genuinely thrilled to see that our curve
has fallen off a cliff there's a spike
last week if you're looking at the chart
it's a it's a false spike because on
that day they added presumptive cases
from the prior three months so that's a
bit of a it looks weird but we've only
got around 200 new cases per day here
there are only a couple hundred people
total I'm talking about in the entire
state left in I see use outdoor dining
is safely reopening i sat outside at a
cafe this weekend I put a picture of me
doing it on Instagram you'll see just
how safe it is but in the meantime while
things are improving dramatically
in many states a ton of right-wing
states that reopened early or never
fully closed are failing hard and it is
difficult to watch in Florida
spiking so aggressively that the chart
I'm showing it almost looks wrong but
that is the real data to the extent that
it is not being understated by Florida
which has been a problem in Florida then
in Texas again cases climbing more and
more and more with worse and worse
looking numbers we look at Arizona where
I have a bunch of friends Arizona it's
climbing in Arizona as if we're at the
beginning their friends told me almost
nobody's wearing masks and doors and
stores
everything's open people are pretending
everything's fine and indeed the case
numbers in Arizona reflect it there are
others we could look at North Carolina
is a big one we're also cases just will
not stop climbing so let's talk about
something now because I want it I want
to deal with the disinformation
propaganda that's going around ahead of
time so that you will be prepared to
fight it when you see it there's a
narrative that we're hearing from the
right that the problem with coronavirus
in the United States is Democrats in
power because the early hotspots are all
liberal cities and Democrats are
terrible at running cities and it's
chaos and that's why we have if it
weren't for democratic led cities this
never would have been a problem in the
United States now most of you know that
that's ridiculous but they will then go
on to say because of those early
failures by democratic governors and
mayors the virus has now spread to red
states even though red states did all of
the right things in blue states that all
of the wrong things they're also now
starting to blame Mexico for some of the
spikes in places like Texas and Arizona
there's no evidence of that so this is a
completely disjointed sort of sort of
Gish gallop narrative that they are
putting together and I want to give you
a coherent sort of unified theory for
what's going on here the early hot spots
were caused by two things population
density and many direct flights to the
area's most affected where the early
cases were coming from right the early
hot spots in the United States were New
York San Francisco
California Chicago Boston as examples
these are four of the densest these
those are actually the four densest
metro areas in the country
not necessarily highest population mmm
but highest population density and they
have tons of flights to Asia and Europe
here in Boston we had non-stop flights
to multiple Chinese cities tons of
flights - even more Chinese cities via
Hong Kong and Tokyo and other places we
had non-stop flights to Italy other
European cities where we now know
coronavirus already was there in late
2019 and early 2020 same thing Illinois
was an early hotspot Chicago O'Hare
Airport major hub for American Airlines
of flights United Airlines I'm going
from memory here San Francisco tons of
flights to China and other Asian
countries were with one stop you can get
to even more cities in China New York
has multiple major airports
New York has LaGuardia Newark and JFK
Newark and JFK both individually are
some of the major gateways to Europe and
to Asia and you had two of them there so
that's why early on the cases started in
those places and right-wing states often
said then we don't have to do that much
because we're not having a problem these
blue states to different degrees lock
down and started mitigation in case is
slowly trickled throughout the country
into red states but a lot of the red
states never fully closed or did but
reopen quickly or did but people ignored
the guidelines and over time the early
hot spots that were brutally hit because
of the population density and the
flights to the hot the the early areas
in Europe and Asia were mitigated but
the red states meanwhile we're just
churning as is a popular new phrase on
the Internet churning cases and when you
look at the timing yeah the blue cities
were the early hot spots but you look at
the curve it was up and then down
because of what was done look at some of
the red states in March they really
weren't having a problem in April they
were only having a small problem but
when you look at the curves now they
haven't even peaked these curves are
horrifying it's just up
up up and in ten days it could be
absolutely insane in some of these
places I'm genuinely glad right now to
be in Massachusetts where everybody's
wearing masks at indoor businesses our
positive test rate is down yesterday it
was like 1.5 percent of all the tests
done yesterday 98.5 percent of the
people tested did not have the virus
that's a very very good sign what's
going on in these other states is
absolutely horrifying now just one more
thing to protect you from disinformation
the right-wingers are also insisting
cases are up in red states because
there's so much testing going on in
those places this is not true the data
is available take Florida as an example
Florida recently had a 36% increase in
new cases but only an 18 percent
increase in testing the positive test
rate went up to 7.5% on that day in
Florida if you test more people and find
a higher percentage of positives that's
not good and they will also say well
cases may be up but hospitalizations and
deaths aren't those are on a 10 to 20
day delay so the cases that are
increasing now will be followed by
deaths and hospitalizations tragically
over the next 10 to 20 days don't fall
for the bogus talking points understand
what's going on and recognize we may not
have a sadist creat ly identifiable
second wave because the first wave may
never end